a thing to realize about John McCain is
that even though he's a child of
privilege and sort of office Oriole if
that's a word expectation of military
achievement he's short just like his
father a grandfather work everywhere
they went when they were kids they were
runts they had a chip on their shoulder
even from people or about people who
thought that they were abusing their own
privilege so John McCain has always been
a scrapper he's been a counter-puncher
and he's always championed the underdog
and in fact saw himself and he even sees
America strangely enough as an underdog
where he feels most psychologically
comfortable is for instance in the sort
of literature that he prefers it's the
scenes where the guy Charlton Heston and
vive sobota is surrounded on all sides
by assassins and he's in the plaza by
himself and it's one man against 120
that's John McCain's favorite scene from
any movie his favorite book is for whom
the bell tolls which is about a noble
mission that's also doomed but the
character Robert Jordan sees it through
to the end knowing that he's basically
going to die because it does it for love
of country and also for the romance of
what McCain himself describes as
beautiful fatalism how does this play
out in the 2008 two presidential
election the cane is most comfortable
when he's the underdog he's in a
psychologically interesting position
when he's down by 10 percentage points
or five percentage points or as in this
year when the GOP is hurting on all
sides and looks like they're going to
lose big in the congressional elections
so going forward if you see John McCain
feeling like he's got his back against
the wall that everyone is counting him
out and says that he can no longer come
back and pull this out you'll probably
notice something interesting he's going
to grin